my favorite example of this well two one
is you could dedicate the remaining
thousand episodes of your podcast
to how short dak shepard is that could
be you could even entitle the podcast
dak shepard is so short too short you
could do a thousand episodes
it'd never bother me because i don't
have any fear of being too short
i am objectively tall i don't have a
fear of being too short so you could
spend the rest of your life trying to
make fun of me for being short and it
wouldn't
bother me now if you had a podcast
called dax is
self-centered and sucks up too much
energy in a room
i'm bothered by that because i do do
that
and i have a fear that i do that and so
it would bother me
intensely and it would bother you but
you know they were right so how what do
you do about that you try to change
yourself
or did you say i'm innately that way
because i do that i'm like i go in a
room
and whether it's insecurity i don't
think they're going to like me for me
i'll be funny i'll be this
it's something that i'm not it's
something that at a young age i did
because i didn't like myself
i wasn't confident with my looks
whatever it was i did and now i
entertain and people like me i'm like
okay i got him i got him now i can
[ __ ] know okay
right so so all that is is an internal
job right
that's a michael rosenbaum job that no
one else has anything to do with
right you can pretend they do but they
don't and and i do think that
all of our problems each individual
person on this planet
their problems have nothing to do with
anyone else
those other people just trigger
their fears and their insecurities
and then that's the problem like if you
had if your
if your self-esteem was literally a
thousand percent
as i'm saying if if my confidence in
every aspect of my personality was the
same as my confidence in that i'm not
short
i wouldn't have problems because
everyone could be saying whatever
they were saying and it would never
bother me so all of
all that to say my only problem is dax
and making sure dax's self-esteem is
it's the optimal level
as high as it can get and then i don't
have problems anymore
i can't wait for the world to change
around me i have to change me
you